24 equipos 11 ciudades 30 días y 50
partidos y todo se reduce al domingo
inglaterra se enfrenta a italia en la
final de la eurocopa 2020 bajo la
dirección de roberto mancini el equipo
italiano atraviesa un buen momento no ha
perdido en 33 partidos por detrás en el
mediocampo jorginho y marcó berti
dirigen sin esfuerzo el juego mientras
que las voces de la experiencia leonardo
bonucci giorgio chiellini forman una
muralla en la defensa la azurri le ha
ganado inglaterra cada vez que se han
enfrentado caras en un campeonato mayor
sin embargo no subestimarán a su rival
porque si no pones todo tu corazón no
puedes ganar una final en wembley contra
inglaterra
tenemos que estar despreocupados y un
poco locos estos ingredientes son los
que nos han permitido llegar donde
estamos y son los que pueden ayudarnos a
ganar el campeonato aunque están
confiados muchos hinchas de italia dicen
que aceptarán cualquier resultado y que
el mejor equipo debe ganar si perdemos
nos quedamos en casa y comemos pasta si
ganamos salimos a celebrar hoy eso es
todo hay que tener esperanza de que
italia lo hará por nosotros
historia espera los tres leones en
wembley han pasado cincuenta y cinco
años desde que la reina isabel entregó
la copa del mundo al entonces capitán
inglés bobby moore ningún equipo inglés
ha logrado llegar a la final en un
campeonato principal hasta ahora pero
con harvey cane encabezando la delantera
y con un ají mestre link disparando
todos los balones y con una rígida
defensa liderada por javi maguire y
johnston los hinchas creen que el
destino podría estar finalmente de su
lado la mayoría de fanáticos van a ser
ingleses
todos están listos para ganar si hay un
tiempo es este habiendo eliminado a
selecciones como alemania y dinamarca en
la recta final el técnico gareth
southgate dice que están listos para un
último empujón y llevar la copa a casa
austin es un juego brillante en el que
participar un juego brillante para
prepararnos para ello estamos en la
final y estamos acá para ganar west wing
con todo en orden ambos equipos buscarán
escribir sus nombres en el folklore
futbolístico pero al final sólo un
equipo podrá coronarse campeón de europa